alright guys I think we're live so last
time in my in the QA I had problems the
sound was extremely was not very good
and so I want to make sure that the
sound is okay because some people were
complaining when they watch it
afterwards that the sound was kind of
weird and echoey
so if there's a problem with the sound
if it's not if the sound is very strange
please tell me so I am told that I sound
lovely today which is which is nice
alright guys so this is the first time
I'm doing this live we'll see how it
goes will we'll check it out and then I
noticed that there's this whole thing I
didn't realize that there was this whole
super chat thing which I never have
never tried before so I don't even know
how to deal with that I guess we'll see
we'll see how it goes if you anybody
puts in the super chat stuff then I'll
try to look at them and see if if
they're questions I'm gonna answer I'm
not gonna answer any question that
appears in the super chance if it's a
question that is ridiculous but if it's
it but if it's a good question then I
will answer it alright so for those who
don't know the way I do this is I I
start with with the questions that were
asked me on patreon and on my website
and on subscribe star for people who are
subscribed at the ten dollar level and
then after that we'll see in the chat if
there any good questions and so here we
go if some of you want to know a little
bit about just news of myself on the
whole the whole flood situation we are
still living in this rented house you
can see this is not the I mean obviously
you're never gonna see that office again
that he used to be in because it's gone
but uh but we're renting a house and
we're not totally still not totally sure
what's going to happen what we're gonna
do if we're gonna go back how we're
gonna go back the government it hasn't
given us all the information yet for us
to decide what's gonna happen so so yeah
so that's the situation I I was
traveling a lot as you have seen on them
on my channel I put up two talks that I
gave in Seattle I'm also going to put up
two talks that I gave in Louisiana I
gave a carving
workshop and I met some some of you guys
too people came I mean I was I guess
three people came mostly because of the
video so it was all we had a lot of fun
during that when we workshop just
talking it up and we spent the last
evening smoking cigars and drinking
whiskey which is always nice so uh so
here we go guys so I don't want it to
last forever and so I'm going to start
with the questions and so I will start
with the questions on my website so
Derrick joel asks what advice would you
give a fellow youtube creators who are
starting up an educational channel what
success failure and important lessons
would you share thank you I alright so
what advice would I give you it's so
funny because I never really decided I
was going to be youtuber it kind of
happened it kind of happened almost
accidentally because I Jordan Peterson
had me on his channel and I and I
started getting a lot of emails and so I
thought you know instead of answering
these emails maybe I should start
putting up videos and a lot of people
were asking me to do more cultural
interpretation so I started doing that
and so I never really did it with a plan
and so one of the things that that I've
seen is it's really it's really tempting
to fall in the YouTube algorithm to try
to please the YouTube algorithm and
that's something that you had you'll
have to fight and that's something that
I'm always trying to fight you know not
to get it because you can see some point
you can start to see what works you know
you make a video on something and it
gets a lot of views then you might be
tempted to do another video on that
subject because it got a lot of views
and I would you know it depends what you
want to do but I would suggest to try to
stay true to what you're doing
I've seen some channels that kind of go
that way
channel that I really respect I won't
name them but there's some channel that
that I was following that used to you
know kind of have critical opinion about
the news where we're kind of critical
about what was happening trying to
analyze it and then when they started to
get popular and get a lot of views I saw
that they started to fall into one
channel where you know you know you've
seen those channels where it's they
start doing criticism of social justice
warriors and they get a lot of views so
then that's all they do and they're just
doing
criticism after criticism negativity I
would say to be careful about the
negativity because you can get a lot of
views with negativity but I don't think
it's very healthy for your soul I've
seen it myself some of my videos where
I'm ranting are some of the videos that
I get the most views the videos where I
criticize something are the videos where
I get the most views but I don't want to
fall into that I don't want it to become
my main thing further for the for the
salvation of my own soul you could say
it's not even it's not even because I
think it's good or bad just because I've
seen what it does to me when you fall
into that space too much you start to
start to get that bile going it's not
that's not good
um one of the things I would suggest is
you know for sure the reason why a lot
of you are on my channel and the reason
why I was able to get some success is
I'm not gonna deny it is because Joanne
Peterson shared my channel and he kind
of helped me out too to succeed and I
would say that it's probably is helpful
to try to connect to other channels that
are doing the types of things that you
want to do and to do it in a way that is
not because I get emails I'll tell you
guys I get emails emails every day of
people asking me you know I wrote this
poem when you read it and give you an
interpretation or you know would you
please look at this thing that I'm doing
and it's not out of bad faith that I
want to that I don't and I don't have
time to do it as I don't have time you
know and so someone asked me to read
their screenplay and then ask you to
criticize it it's I mean it's not gonna
happen I just don't have time but what
I've noticed is when somebody does
something to help me out somebody who
who who let's say will do a very good
criticism of one of my videos will post
a video about one of my videos then I'll
watch it you know it's something that
that is that can kind of help me get
better or help I'll help me out and what
I'm trying to accomplish if you can help
someone in what they're trying to
accomplish then it's easier to get their
attention the reason why Jordan ended up
sharing my videos because that
metaphysics of Peppe video I spend weeks
and weeks thinking about it trying to
present it in a way that that wasn't
damaging to his reputation because I
knew it was it was iffy that could that
subject was iffy and it was
being people were accusing that meme of
being horrible meme and everything and
so when I put that second part up I
could tell that that I had upped the
amount of trust that Jordan had in me
and because that I I had reached that
amount of trust then that I think that's
one of the reasons why he's decided to
to still share some of my stuff and so I
would say the same you know
if you're trying to start something a
blog or a YouTube channel or whatever
look at the people that you admire that
are doing something good and try to see
if you can do something for them and and
that will help to that'll help that'll
help them remember you like they have
you in their mind and to think of
sharing your content or or to to help
you out if they can so that's the advice
that I can give because that I guess is
how I did it so alright who go so do
veils David Florence asks do veils and
ornaments reveal more about what they
are covering it seems that because you
are focused more on what it's hidden you
learn more at least about what you can
see so that is the whole that is in a
way the whole mystery of Revelation the
the idea of revealing revealing is a
weird word because it has something to
do with putting a veil back on something
so it's like taking the veil away but
also putting a valence like the word
seems to mean both at the same time the
the the value of veiling something is
that you're inadvertently showing that
this is precious you're protecting it
you know you are putting something over
it in order to cover it so that it's not
it's not vulgar you know it's not
available for everybody you're making it
precious and by making it precious
you're then it can help you to I also
understand why it's precious you know
you you would you are not gonna veil
your hamburger because no one cares
about your hamburger but you will take
you know your precious watch and
precious ring and put it in a nice
little drawer you know so that it's
hidden not just out there for anybody to
pick up right and so it's the same with
with sacred things in general and it's
also the same to be honest with with
with with the idea of a woman who
vail part of the notion of a woman who'd
wear a veil in church has to do with
also pointing to this this idea of the
holy place as well that just like the
holy places veil so - the woman is
veiled because she's precious because
you know to - to reveal the the female
form for everybody to see is like
throwing pearls to swine as well um and
so I I totally agree with David on that
idea
okay so Belize one-two-three-four asks
what do you believe the connection
between love goodness beauty and truth
is is there a hierarchy or are they
equal the way I have thought of
conceptually concept conceptualizing it
is almost like Trinity within the
Trinity these are just my thoughts I
would appreciate it if you could help me
better understand this connection if one
exists thank you um I mean it depends
like if you put love and goodness
because if you put love and goodness as
if those are the same thing I'm not sure
love and goodness are the same thing I
would say that goodness beauty and truth
do you act as a kind of as a kind of
Trinity in the sense that that they go
together because one alone can actually
be dangerous you know one oh if you if
you just have if you just have goodness
without truth you it can become a kind
of you know like you would spoil a child
if you have just truth without goodness
then you also you know you might have
you know cutting sword you need both at
the same time and you need Beauty also
as the revelation of that of those truth
and that goodness so I think that love
is the highest of all I think that love
is is the very life of God talked about
this a few times in my in my in my talk
love is the very possibility of of
multiplicity and unity coexisting and so
I believe that it has it has the highest
metaphysical place you could say I hope
that answers all right
all right so we've got a whole bunch of
questions by Jesse Blaney let's see if I
if we're gonna go through all of them
but let's at least start and we'll see
all right so Jesse Blaney asks hey
Jonathan as usual I have a few tough
questions that combine symbolism and
tradition I'm about to propose to my
girlfriend was announcing this and I'm
about to propose to my girlfriend and
I've started to look into the tradition
of wedding rings so question number 1
which part of the universal wedding
traditions are worth participating in as
a Christian I mean I don't know what
your tradition is I would say that you
should participate in those that are
part of your tradition I would I would
say that in a certain manner that
shouldn't be your choice completely you
should try it if you're if I I guess
with the fact that you asked that
suggest that you're that you are
Protestant and so so I would say you
know I I don't know I would say that the
best thing is to have something that's
coherent and to not just pick and choose
and to follow so I would say look into
the the wedding traditions of the east
and the west and you know if you're if
you're not Orthodox if you're a Western
Christian I would say for sure the
wedding ring is the last remainder of
the of the highest the idea of the veil
the white dress you know although things
the veil I think is is could be an
interesting thing to to still have you
know those are I think those very
important all right let's see what you
talk you talk about another thing so I
know that there is Orthodox of wearing
the ring on the right hand and not the
left being the right hand is for
righteousness
what would the left hand be if I can
guess is right here it is a protect and
serve duality to each hand is another
type of inversion happening in our
society so the thing about the thing
about the right and the left hand which
is extremely complicated to understand
and I'm probably gonna make some videos
on the right and the left hand is that
just because something is on the left
like let's say you have the notion of a
ring on the left hand or a ring on the
right hand so you can understand it this
way both of them can actually symbolize
the same thing it just depends on how
you perceive it because when
I'm standing in front of somebody my
right hand is their left hand and
they're my left hand is their right hand
and so let's say that I am with my right
hand I am placing your ring
you know I'm placing with my right hand
my ring the the the ring on your left
hand and so your left hand corresponds
to my right hand you are my right hand
right and so you could see it as a
binding in that manner I don't know if
that makes sense but you could also see
it the other way which is that you wear
the ring on your right hand as you said
because it is the it's the hand it's the
straight hand is the hand of
righteousness so I wear my ring ring on
my my right hand let's say but if I wear
it on my left hand he could also mean
like I said that I am the right hand of
my spouse right so it doesn't right and
left is very complicated to understand
it's not it's not that complicated you
actually have you actually have to look
at the symbolism itself just somehow
sometimes know whether something is left
hand or right hand symbolism all right
hope that makes sense all right let's
see number three I've just finished
reading your brother's book the language
of creation what do you think is the
symbolism of reading me so we continue
on with this wedding ring
I either robro symbol or is it closer to
her the idea of meta space being a ring
that is crown protecting the Gloria or
of a jewel could it be a duality of both
time space or singular so the wedding
ring isn't very complicated it's really
is the definition of a it's a binding
it's a binding of something so you can
imagine that you have the the feminine
you know in the ancient days if you read
in the Bible it was just the man who
would put the ring on the woman you know
I don't know when it happened that both
would wear rings but it's the idea that
you have this this thing that is not
yours
and then you bind it to you and so
you're putting a you're putting a ring
around it your your encircling it like
you would encircle land like you would
put a fence around land you are
encircling the land in order to show
that it is yours and so putting a ring
on a finger is to say you know this
woman this man is mine right it's a
binding of that person to you and so
that's why it's a ring right and that's
why it's that's why you put it around
why the other person will put it on the
you know the the spouse will put it on
their their spouse the husband who put
on their wife the wife who put on their
husband because it's saying this person
belongs to me I'm binding them and
putting his face around them you know um
just like I would put a wall around my
house or your like I said like a fence
alright so talking about Matthew's book
I number four I think there are some
chapters in the book I talk about
mixture and purity and seals and
ornaments my intuition is that these
relate to the topic of marriage as I
know there's a hierarchy in gold and a
style that mixes it with other materials
I have an idea to get two rings and have
one of them marked as an ornament and
I'm not sure what you're getting at here
so so the idea that that the ring is an
ornament is is just watch my watch my
video on the Lord of the Rings I really
talked about this idea of the periphery
or the edge that it's a binding it's a
protection you know you're saying you're
if you put a wall around the city you're
saying this is mine but you're also
putting this wall as as a border but
then it can also be an ornament it's a
it is a supplement right it is a
supplement which is showing how
something is is together right it's it's
a sign to to to show that something is
bound right and so and so the the ring
is is an ornament right and it plays the
role of an ornament as well you know
ornament is not is not it's not bad
there's nothing wrong with with
ornaments they just have to have the
right the right space and so the idea of
putting a gold band is of course is of
course a a you know you can imagine you
can imagine it like as the highest
binding you know the the highest thing
that's bound on the I think it's on the
altar the in the Old Testament or is it
the altar or is it the actual Ark of the
Covenant I think it's the altar
I think it's knowing might be the Ark of
the Covenant where there's a braid
around the the periphery of the box you
know and that's this golden braid that
goes around this golden braids sent it
from the Syria
compares this golden braid that
surrounds the altar of the Ark of the
Covenant to the very limit of the Garden
of Eden as this this limit which holds
the whole world together you know and so
you can imagine the whole world having a
ring around it you know and it and the
arrow Burroughs that's what it is
the arroba Rose is not necessarily bad
it can it's a it is an image of this
this border this cat this ornament if I
if I use the word chaos it might might
be problematic in descent but this idea
of something which is added to something
else which is like the last the last
thing around it and so that's what
that's what it is in terms of a terms of
a ring in marriage as well all right so
I would say watch my video on the Lord
of the Rings I talk I think I even talk
about the the wedding ring as well in
there all right
and so Jessie Leigh need one more
question she says after thought on the
question of the Rings why has it become
taboo now for the ring of the husband to
have a jewel is it to show a sign of
humility that the only ring of the wife
is crown does this relate to the
symbolism of hair I don't I don't really
know what it's true that men today don't
wear jewels most of the time it seems
like like jewels have been related to
the feminine it might have to do that
men men now don't want to have excessive
ornamentation in general and and you can
understand why masculinity in some
respect would be would would want to
avoid ornamentation in another way in
other culture than in other times it was
actually the reverse where men were far
more ornamented and women were less
ornamented you know the times of the
Knights or like the Masai for example is
a culture where the men are have all the
hair braided and they wear all this all
these these ornaments you know kind of
like a in some you know this idea that
in some races of about some species of
birds you know the male is very very
flamboyant so you can have that also but
in our culture it seems to be the
opposite it really seems that the woman
is
the one who is ornamented and the man is
more sober
alright so david Flores asked could you
do a symbolic interpretation of
Netflix's I am mother I have not I have
not seen that that yet so maybe I could
check it out I don't know it depends I
don't you know it's so funny because
people don't really realize that I'm not
I actually don't watch a lot of
television I don't watch a lot of movies
once in a while I'll kind of give myself
the luxury of watching a watching a
series or a movie you knows and
sometimes it's actually like when I'm
not doing well and and I don't want to
go to bed and evening and then I watch
and usually not that I'm actually
usually not in a very good space when I
end up watching a lot of Netflix or a
lot of movies I actually you know that
this series that I just watched was I
watched the Good Omens series by Neil
Gaiman there Neil Gaiman and Terry
Pratchett I watched that on on prime and
so you'd be interesting to maybe talk
about that talk about Neil Gaiman and
his uh his his vision of mythological
structures maybe one day I'll make a
video about that alright alright so NC
Watson asks hello Jonathan I have a
question regarding the so called problem
of evil and its relationship to
principalities I have recently read
doors of the sea by David Bentley Hart
it discusses the problem of evil and
articulates the Christian response to it
however I'm not sure I understand it
entirely well I haven't read David
Bentley's Hart's book but for sure that
problem is is the central problem of
humanity and so it's not easy to answer
it I don't think that anybody will ever
give you an answer that will be
completely satisfactory in the last Q&A
I believe you discuss how humans and
humans and spiritual beings in what
seems paradoxical have the autonomy to
turn away from God for my understanding
this turning away is essentially the
root of evil I can understand this in
the context of human evil but I'm unsure
what to make of this in the context of
something like a natural disaster
I believe it's somehow related to
principalities but that's about all I
could gather if you could elaborate on
this I would appreciate it thanks so um
yeah I don't know I don't know if you
could say the same if you could see
the same thing that evil and disasters
are the same I don't necessarily think I
think that disasters are related to
death and death and evil are not the
same thing and so death is the the
tendency of things to decompose that you
break apart and so it is true that in
the Bible death is seen as a consequence
of sin but that's that the mystery the
mystery and when I post the talk I talk
I I did in Louisiana I talked about this
mystery which is this mystery that in
fact the death and glory are related
they're actually you could say they're
actually the same thing but one is
flipped like one is below and one is
above but they're like the same the same
reality which is why the cross ends up
being the highest thing the highest
manifestation in in the human history
because it joins both of them together
it joins death and glory together
completely and so so the idea the idea
is that Christians are have the capacity
to flip it to flip death and turn it
into a glory and so that will take
different shapes in different moments
but you know the idea of martyrdom all
these ideas are moments where you can
see the death becomes glory and so it's
difficult it's difficult to understand
because we we don't want to die you know
and we protect ourselves from death with
reason you know but but that seems to be
there seems to be a relationship there
in in both and it might give us the key
to understanding death the purpose of
death let's say you know and evil is
different like evil what evil is is it
really is that the capacity to think
that you are you are the totality of
being that's always what evil ends up
being is that is that you think you're
better you're more important than God
that's what evil is the root of all evil
is always pride if that's the
the person is that you think that you're
higher than God and that you judge God
or you judge reality if you I mean it
might be easier for people to understand
that and somehow reality should be met
we should be happening differently you
know and therefore I am going to twist
to the truth I'm going to twist things
in order to shape the world to my will
in a you know in my will in the sense of
my desires you know my trying to get
things for myself because I think that
I'm more important than the people
around me and I end up using end up
turning people into tools I end up you
know transforming love and relationships
into into relationships of you know
pragmatic relationships trying just
trying to get things from people and so
that's the but then that also causes
death sin causes death right the wages
of sin is death because if you do that
then things start to break apart so I
hope this answers I'm not going to give
you like the ultimate the ultimate
answer to the problem of evil because
you know the answer is e the answer is
simple the answer is the cross you know
but then that's not enough like I can
tell you that but it's hard to know what
that entails or what that completely
what that means let's say alright okay
so so the same person so believes one
two three four ask another question said
sorry I had one more question I want to
ask one that might be difficult to fully
articulate in the last Q&A you mentioned
that Christ on the cross looks like a
serpent and that this symbol is embedded
in our consciousness an idea that I had
in relation to this image is that when
we choose to follow Christ due to our
fallen natures we will not be perfect
and sin the curves outside the cross are
the moments when we sin and when we get
back to the center we are coming back to
God
it's path for us you also mentioned that
it is like a Cirque a cycle so maybe the
cycle gets narrower as you get closer to
perfection and as it gets wider you are
getting farther from perfections I was
also thinking Christ shaped snake like
shape could be a reflection of sins of
those that crucified him apart from the
actual crucifixion itself of course
read your article servants of Orthodoxy
and most probably need to read it more
fully to understand this thank you for
reading and tolerating my strange
question it's not a strange question if
anybody has not read my article called
the the serpents of Orthodoxy I would
suggest you read it I think that some of
your ideas are quite good in terms of
this idea that you know you have the
access then you have this cycle you can
imagine the snake as going like this you
can also imagine it as a spiral that's
going up or down you know so you have
this spiral which comes to the center
and kind of moves away from the center
something like that or like a wave right
that goes back to the center then moves
moves away and so on the one hand you
can understand it exactly as you said as
this death is moving away from the tree
and coming back to the tree is this kind
of cycle of the the cycle of death right
the the cycle of the passions you could
say but you don't necessarily have to
see it that way you can also see it in a
positive light which is that it is the
it is the let's say the love of God
which goes out and comes back to God and
so the influence the spiritual influence
of the center of the tree of the of the
logos goes out into the world and then
brings the world back into God and so it
all depends on memory it all depends on
whether or not that which is outside the
center remembers that which is inside
and so although you can as you said
imagine it as these smaller and smaller
cycles that move into the heart you know
the church fathers talk about this
moving into the heart and you can
imagine that these circles that get
smaller and smaller as you get closer
and closer to the center to the core to
the heart you can see it that way as
well but then these Saint Ephrem this
hearing again has this beautiful image
or or even st. dionysius the areopagite
he talks about the three movements of
the soul so he talks about the circular
movement of the soul which is the soul
which is contemplating which is you know
which is in the heart you could say and
contemplating God and so it's kind of
turning around God in that sense then he
talks about linear movement which is
this moving
way from from God so the linear movement
is kind of like this forgetting and
moving away but then he talks about the
spiral and he talks about the spiral as
the joining of the two together and this
moving out and moving back in you know
saying Saint Ephrem the Syrian talks
about he talks about how the children of
light they descend the the slopes of the
Garden of Eden and they can walk on the
waters of the flood you know and then
they come back and so it's not about how
far you are from the center it's really
about ultimately it's about if you
remember if you get you can go very far
if you remember the center once you
forget that's when things start to break
apart that's when things start to to to
fragment okay hope this makes sense
Kevin you can watch the last the last
talk I gave in Seattle the the talk I
gave in Seattle the one called I think
it's called it's called miss something
about mysticism like the anthropology of
mysticism if you can watch that you can
get a sense of it and my next one of the
videos I'm gonna put out in the next few
weeks on sin Ephraim the Syrian I really
talked about I'm going to show you this
beautiful image of paradise and how he
he creates his cosmology in his text a
more fully I know a lot of people have
asked me a lot of people have been
asking me it's like oh I read Saint
Ephrem the Syrians book that you
recommended but I'm just not getting
what you're saying out of it so so I'm
gonna so I've already recorded I'm gonna
take you guys on a trip on that trip
hopefully you'll uh you'll appreciate
that all right okay next next a question
level I'm gonna get this from subscribe
star so Keenan Cronin asks I go to an
evangelical church and I recently went
to my first Orthodox service I loved the
liturgy and the veneration of the icons
and the choir but I really struggle to
understand it because other than the
Lord's Prayer the entire service was in
Greek yes well could you please give
some advice to someone interested in
orthodoxy but who might not have access
to a church that is in their native
language um it's tough man it's tough if
you do not have access to a church in
your native language you know I don't
know where you live in in North America
we have two jurisdictions and
Orthodox Church which really make an
effort to reach out to English speakers
and that's the OCA and the Antiochian
church and so if you are in a if you are
in a place that you can find an OC a
church or a or an Antiochian Church I
think that could help you with the name
like Keenan Cronin
I'm thinking maybe you're not American
that's possible I don't know he who
knows we all have all kinds of names in
America but so I don't know I don't know
if you're in Europe that might mean more
that might be more difficult ultimately
what you would like to do is to if you
if you really are interested and the
services in Greek what you want to do
and you want to continue to go to this
Orthodox Church what you want to do is
to get a copy of the Liturgy of st. John
Chrysostom and you can follow the
service in English as it's happening of
course you can maybe get some help from
you from the priest or from someone to
help you understand where you are in the
service but that way you can at least
follow the service and follow the
prayers as they're being chanted in
Greek you can follow them in English
it's a bit of an effort but but but
you'll find it very rewarding if you can
if you can figure that out all right
okay so let's go to the patreon
questions
all right I'm seeing that oh there are
quite a few of these these super chat
things so I know don't worry I will get
to all these these super chats and
hopefully I can kind of go through the
the comments section and see if there's
interesting stuff in there all right and
I won't read the obscenities in of the
super chats it's not happening I'm not
gonna read everything you write it all
the scat the scatological comments are
not going to be read all right okay so
Laura shields asked do you have any
inside information on the upcoming
Bishop Baron Peterson dialogue release
what do you hope from it I have no way I
have no information I know Jordan
recorded it and I know Bishop Baron
talked about it I don't I didn't even
watch the thing the bishop Baron says I
I think that that I don't know if you
guys have watched that that's the that's
something you can find sure Jordan's
gonna put it out on his podcast soon
do I hope from it hahaha I don't know I
don't know what I hope from it you know
the the guys from the free speech club
are in the chat tonight what I hoped was
that we were good an organize an event
with the three of us together that was
their plan the vancouver free speech
club guys but that did not materialize
so I hope I hope you know Bishop Baron
is extremely smart man and he's also
understands the ontology and the
metaphysics of Christianity very well
compared to most people and so I'm
hoping that he can he can talk about God
in a way that that Jordan will click
that will help him to understand what it
is that we're talking about and maybe
we'll remove some of the barriers that
he has in yeah removes on the Bears that
he has in in in that in that area but he
recorded a while ago and I don't think
anything's changed you know he did that
video about you know who could say they
believe in God where Jordan is saying
that he doesn't want to say that he
believes in God because the idea of
believing in God is actually so heavy
that to really say that would would
would kind of condemn you because no one
is completely acting completely living
in a manner which shows that they
actually do believe in God
so somebody to think about you know okay
so here we go let's say Lord Jill's also
says I came I came home to a house
disaster the day after Easter oh my
goodness we that happen to us the day
the the Easter Easter Saturday that's
crazy
so I lived out of my home for almost
well so almost a month it will take
months for all the repairs where I'm
wondering if you have gleaned any
positive about your experience God we
ordered my summer in ways that although
difficult might be part of his plan not
saying I love the way I got reordered
but wonder if you perceived anything
similar I think that you know as as we
that's been like 2 months now since the
flood has happened I would say that most
of it has actually been amazing in terms
of seeing the amount of
that people have surrounded us with you
know my family our friends people
helping us out you know people helping
me out financially people sending me
books you know I've got I received a
whole bunch of books from people I get I
put up an Amazon book wish list for
people who wanted to to to help me
rebuild my library and I got all these
books and it's cool cuz I'm writing down
the names of the people who sent me the
books in the book so that every time I
open the book I'll have this memory that
someone who cares for me someone who was
thinking about me has sent me the book
and so it's really it's really made me
felt surrounded by by by love and you
know there's been some amazing things
coming out of it we were able to find a
house and our children are living in a
village now and it's like old school
village where the kids are just outside
all the time there are all these kids of
the village kids are there and you know
they're out you know my my youngest
daughter is there she she'll call me at
8 o'clock and Sam at this friend's house
and we know the parents we trust them
and so it's and she'll come back by foot
and we don't worry we don't think about
it it's pretty amazing because where we
were was more like a suburb kind of like
the dark suburbs where nobody knows each
other and everything so that's been
amazing I would say I would say that
that that disasters are an opportunity
to restart some things you know they're
an opportunity to to to press restart so
you know we always have this desire to
do it and sometimes we can't because we
don't we don't end up doing it because
there's so many things pulling us but
when the disaster happens it's like you
know I had to throw away half of all my
stuff you know my everything is our
house is a wreck you know the basement
is gone and the you know the upper level
is also ruined because the the we had
tubes the carpet got ruined because of
the the flood we had to take things out
and everything and so it's like we
actually have to we have to if we're
gonna go back to our house we're gonna
have to rebuild it and so yeah it's an
opportunity to do that it's an
opportunity to say huh then how can we
do it differently now because we don't
have a choice and so I think that that's
the that's the positive aspect of of a
disaster you know is is that you you end
up having to restart and sometimes that
can be positive you know but I mean it's
been tough you know I've gained like
gained like 10 15 pounds
just because you know my whole eating is
gone out of control and you know as you
saw like I was just getting really
scruffy like I was not shaving anymore
my beard was getting weird and then my
hair was kind of full back and just kind
of getting messy and stuff so I decide
to get a haircut got it you know kind of
restart everything ha ha ha ha now I
need to restart my diet is what I need
to do stop moving or something all right
ok so Norman Wintermute asks I've heard
many accuse you of only looking at the
Bible symbolically and discounting the
historicity of events found within I
understand that the stories found in
Scripture can be analyzed and understood
in themselves whether or not they
actually happened in the history but for
the slanderers and haters out there
can you please explicitly clarify your
position on whether separate to the
symbolic interpretation you accept and
affirm the historicity of the events of
the Holy Scripture by the way I know you
addressed this before but it keeps
coming up especially with Jay dyers
followers quitting my view tend to
slander you and misconstrue your
position on this issue and I think that
that's that's it like you said I think
that you know I don't I don't I never
completely understood that whole thing
you know I know that that that that
people on the J dire side of things are
are accusing me and attacking me
I've had people write me in private
constantly asking like can you please
like you do now like can you affirm can
you affirm it's like I've I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna spend my time doing that
because I don't feel like I need I have
anything to prove to Jay Dyer and to his
followers you know I actually don't mind
Jay you know I think that a lot of
things he says are good some things he
says I don't agree with but I don't feel
like I had to prove anything to them I'm
in good standing with my bishop I'm in
good standing with the OCA with the
priests around me they invite me to give
talks I have never said anything which
suggests that I don't believe that
what's described in the Bible is
describing events and so and like I said
I've I've I've said it and and I think
that for example like the way that you
knew you um you phrase a question I
think it's important to understand
because it's good to think about it
because you say can you please
especially clarifying position on
whether separate to the his symbolic
interpretation you accept and affirm the
historicity of the events of the Holy
Scriptures and it's like I would not do
that I do not believe that there is a
historical historicity of the events
separate from their and symbolic
interpretation those two things come
together symbolism is the manner in
which things come together and so the
manner in which we describe events the
man in which events are seen as an
actual event that's a symbolic process
you could not describe an event without
symbolism because the the the contour of
the event can scatter into infinite
details we've talked about this so many
times you know why is it that I'm
talking about you know this aspect of
the event instead of talking about how
the guys foot dragged on the floor while
the event was happening or you know how
the dog was barking you know two blocks
from there the the the contour of the
event is necessarily symbolic okay now I
do not believe that the Bible describes
events in a manner which modern
historians would acknowledge as being
historical but I don't see that as a
problem because I don't think the way
that modern historians view the the
contour and event as having as having
that much value I don't I don't think I
think that they're unconscious about the
symbolism they're unconscious about how
how an event is construed and so I
actually prefer the the the the manner
in which an event is described in the
Bible I think that it's more powerful
that it actually is more compressing
reality into something which can help us
know how to live you know um
and so I always tell people it's like I
have no problem in saying that the
events of the Bible happened but at the
same time I also don't have a problem in
saying that the Trojan War happened and
I also don't have a problem in in
declaring some of the events that are
told in ancient stories as having
happened either you know it doesn't that
doesn't I don't I don't
because historians will question those
as well and like I don't care what
historians say I see these I see these
these events being remembered
being brought being brought together
being being presented to us in a manner
which helps us understand reality and
but I think they're talking about events
I do not believe that the ancients sat
around and made up stories just out of
their out of their head you know there
when they're talking about events
they're doing it remembering something
and telling it in a manner which is
transformative of reality I hope that I
hope that that that settles it for for
once but I but like I said I really
don't feel like I owe I owe these I owe
the the these people on on anyways there
are some people who are just looking to
find fault in other in other people's
thoughts and and those you know they say
haters you know that's there's gonna be
that everywhere and the Internet is is
insane like that
you can't I'm not I'm not gonna base
what I say on that I'm gonna just say my
thing I love the church I love the
father's I love the Bible you know that
is the core of what I I base my life on
and so if you still want to come after
me because you don't like the way that I
phrase that then dude too bad talk to my
bishop you know get me excommunicated do
that
all right so call your Kirkland asks is
the nature of God's static and complete
or dynamic and in the process of
becoming how does this relate to the
concept of man being made in the image
of God and God's incarnation through the
flesh Oh as Jesus I think that I think
the best way to understand God is as
infinite and and transcending those
categories for sure I think we talked
about that before but I do also think
that there is something in orthodoxy it
seems like in the West there is a
tendency to believe that God is is
stasis you know this idea of the the
divine nature as this stasis and also
even this idea of salvation as stasis
whereas because of the infinite nature
of God in the Orthodox tradition we do
tend to see God as as a dynamic relation
of love between the persons of the
Trinity you know not in the sense that
they change but in the sense that they
are like when you say process of
becoming I think that that's that's a
that's a problematic term if you're
talking about that God does not that God
does not contain outside of time and in
infinity all you know all that God is
you know that I would I would I would
disagree with but in step but then I
nice that this idea of a static was of a
dynamic relationship within the Trinity
complete dynamic relationship I don't
know Houston I don't how to phrase it
I'm not a theologian but for sure we
don't Orthodox Christians don't tend to
see God is simply static alright okay so
XRD ask here's a video game related
question all right some people on the
left are having a massive freakout about
a concept in an upcoming game cyberpunk
2077 20 2077 the games world excessive
cybernetic augmentations often involving
replacing entire parts of the body was
said by one of the developers to make it
so that the individual's body is no
longer sacrum sacred but profound
profane they produced that person's
connection to the meat this makes me
think of your use of embodiment any
thoughts of that or transhumanism in
general I I'm really impressed actually
by that I did see that go by that that
people were criticizing it and I think
it I think it's very impressive
that they're able to understand you know
when we talk about garments of skin you
know and the notion of this of the
transhumanism and the cybernetic self as
I do the cyborg is is really a
mythological representation of the
garments of skin we're already cyborgs
you know in reality we're already
cyborgs because we drive cars because we
you know we we use tools just using a
tool makes you somehow a cybernetic
being of course the the the science
fiction version of it makes it more
compelling or more you know radicalizes
that idea of the cyborgs and and brings
the the it's you know like attachment to
the bodies and replacing body parts and
stuff but I do think that the notion of
the of the virgin body is something that
is worth thinking about you know in in
terms of that cybernetic symbolism this
idea of a pure body and a body that
hasn't been that has not been
transformed you know in in the
scriptures you often get the the altars
the ancient altars the one that were
done made before the temple were had to
be made out of uncut stone stone that
was not cut by a man so it was like this
notion of a pure space that hasn't
received any form of transformation and
I think that that's definitely a symbol
of virginity a symbol of ultimately of
the mother of God and so and so it's
it's interesting that their phrasing it
that way and that in a some manner
they're seeing the problem of
augmentation even within a game that is
all about augmentation and about that so
so cheers to them you know maybe they're
watching my videos probably not though
you funny if that was true all right
here we go
so drew McMahon asks I've heard a
prominent Catholic I follow say that the
responsibility of the individual is to
get to heaven but the responsibility of
a father is to get himself and his wife
and children to heaven
what's your reaction to this well I mean
in theory those two things are the same
you know in theory in theory as you as
you are saved as you yourself are healed
and we have to see it really as a
healing and you yourself are heal from
your passions as you are able to be free
from the things that are pulling you
apart what's going to happen inevitably
going to happen is that your love will
grow your love for the others will grow
and in that love you can save others you
know you can you can participate in the
salvation of others and especially in
your family and so I I do believe that
that those two things are the same it's
only that of course a a in a family you
know it maybe it's more apparent because
because your children are dependent on
you and so they are actually your
children are actually
of you that's tough to think about but
the idea that your children are in some
way an extension of you they manifest
you in different aspects of you and so I
think that that's that's something to
think about and so by you yourself
gathering gathering in and you know and
entering into the heart and all that I
think that you will be participating in
the salvation of those that are
dependent on you and those around you as
well
all right so drew mcmahon also asked hey
Jonathan to keep things light I'm
wondering if you can comment on abortion
yeah that always keeps things light do
you think that there is any way to find
common ground on a topic like this which
seems to be binary it appears to be a
winner-take-all scenario where one group
will inevitably have extreme resentment
can pro-choice and pro-life people ever
find common ground
should this be one of the most important
issues for a Christian to be concerned
with I do not think that it should be
one of the most important issues for a
Christian to be concerned with I think
that the very fact that we have come to
a society that has accepted abortion
means that we are really really far down
the road that our society has broken
away from Christianity has broken away
from from some of the essential elements
of understanding what it being is
understanding you know what a mother is
understanding what a family is
understanding what self-sacrifice is
understand all these things we've lost
you know and and abortion is is a
symptom of that and so I don't think
that I think that people who spend their
time fighting abortion are fighting the
symptom they're not fighting the the
cause and you and that's why it'll end
up it's not you're not going to win that
fight back I have nothing against people
who who are politically active against
abortion but I but to be honest I do not
certainly don't think that it's the most
important issue for Christian to be
concerned with um I don't think that
there's a way to find common ground on
that topic I do think that
I do think one of the problems with
abortion like all the problems of this
marginal behavior are these marginal
things that are happening is that we are
trying we don't when you're trying to
make them public and make them publicly
accepted we're trying to get we want to
make them legal in every sense of that
we want to make them societally
acceptable and there are some things
which can never be societally acceptable
and there are some things which will
always exist in the in the margins and
exist in the in the secret places but
the problem is that which we want to to
shine light on them and then say that
it's fine and that's not that's not that
that's never going to that's not
possible
and so you know the idea of if is it
possible that there's a situation where
a woman should get an abortion you know
the official question obviously is know
you know but then we all know that there
are situations health situations that
there that there are all kinds of
situation where the life of the woman is
in danger and it's not obvious to make a
choice one way or the other and so I
don't and I think that those are what we
call economía in the our orthodox church
that is there are the things that are
that are looked upon in their particular
and are not are not understood as being
as being normative you know um I hope
that answers that question but but but
like he's I don't think that I don't
think that first why I don't think that
will ever have common ground on that and
I also don't think that it's the most
important thing Christians we focus on
all right so mark Peters says could you
speak more about the tree of knowledge
of good and evil the apples were as good
as any other in the garden and the only
thing that set them apart was God's
command not to eat might its fruit in
his in his own way sorry forgot okay my
god have allowed them to eat had the
allowed God to present them with its
fruit in his own way rather than they're
taking it willfully in icons of the
garden you said the tree was blah
their direct view of the Tree of Life is
all this and after view of what took
place or does the blocking of their view
represent the truth of the garden
conditions prior to the servants
entrance so you've got it right Marquis
you've definitely have it right and the
next talk like told you I recorded his
talk on Sunday from the Syrian Saint
Ephrem talk specifically about that san
Ephraim says that if Adam and Eve had
not taken the fruit on their own then
God would have given them the fruit you
know the idea and you see that if you
understand the symbolism of Christ you
understand that Christ is eating the
fruit of the knowledge of good and evil
you know and he's transforming that
death into glory and so the way that
Saint Ephrem sees it is that the the
tree of the knowledge of good and evil
Adam and Eve were placed in the middle
of the garden so you imagine the garden
as a mountain Adam and Eve were placed
in the middle where the tree of the good
of the knowledge of good and evil was
and the tree of the knowledge of good
and evil acted as a veil which prevented
them from seeing the the glory above but
also prevented them from seeing death
below you could say and so what would
Saint Ephrem says is that what God
wanted was that in humility obey God and
then God would have given them the fruit
of the knowledge of good and evil you
know the fruit of duality you could say
and then both our eyes would have been
open the eye that sees good in the eyes
that sees that sees evil and one eye
you know that's what happened to them
even when they did eat the fruit but
that if they did it in humility then
they could have ascended to the higher
place and then they would have also they
would he talks about in a great way he
says they would have seen both health
and sickness but they would have seen it
as someone who's healthy understands
sickness but now because they took it
for themselves they understand health
from the point of view of someone who's
sick and then views health so it's a
good way to show that image that what
the idea was that they needed to to
accept it in humility and then ascend up
so that then they could even see the
possibility of evil but that it would
have been from someone above looking
below
and now it's from someone below looking
above um and so it's a really
interesting if you think about that for
a while I'm not gonna give you all the
secrets of that because I want you to
watch my talk but if you think about
that for a while it can help you to
understand the mystery of what it is to
be human as well in the right hand in
the left hand
all that stuff is really nice and
contained in that in that structure so
alright so norm go they ask and you
speak about fasting during Lent and
Advent I've been looking for ideas but
haven't been able to find much in terms
of tradition or rules it is more is it
more of an individual thing or though
their rules somewhere about this yes if
you want to find the the rules in the
Orthodox Church there are specific rules
for fasting during Advent and Lent you
can also see it as a hierarchy to a
certain extent as well because there you
know it's very important to understand
that fasting is not in the Church
Fathers always insist that the real
fasting is the interior fasting that's
the real fasting you do need to fast
exteriorly in terms of of certain foods
in terms of certain practices but you
also have to not you have to do an
interior fast which is to try to cut
yourself away from the passion so that's
very important um but if you if you look
online just look Orthodox rules for Lent
you'll find you know you don't eat meat
you don't eat fish at some point you
don't eat dairy dairy products you only
eat vegetables and you can also eat some
shellfish and then on Sundays you know
some traditions you can eat fish on
Sundays and have wine on Sundays no
other wine during the week so there are
rules that you can follow and the rules
are good because the rules are not from
you they're not something that you
choose there's something that are chosen
for you and because they're chosen for
you then they they are something which
manifest your humility you have to
submit to something which is exterior to
you and what it does it shows you how
weak you are because oh my goodness it's
so funny because you know you could any
day decide not to eat certain things and
you gets no problem but when there's a
rule and you have to follow it for
certain amount of weeks all of a sudden
it's like oh man that cheese looks
really good it's like oh you know it's
not a big deal it's not a big deal you
know all of a sudden you know you you
can you can discover yourself you
discover just how weak
you are and how you have these different
personalities in your mind that switch
on you know and all of a sudden you know
yeah it it's it's it's definitely
something that's worth the the exercise
all right so no I'm whole day talks
about I really enjoyed the videos on
time and space particularly how you
explored the idea of compression of time
and modern technological conveniences
I'm not sure though what I that I
understand what you mean by space fixing
time as mentioned in the title walls
prevent change how space fixes time can
you expand on this idea a bit more and
so it's really important to understand
change time as change and not just as
the you know if you read Matthew's book
you really insist on that that
traditional you have to understand time
has changed and not time just as you
know a succession of events you could
say and so I mean the way that space
fixes time is that if you if you imagine
imagine you are you are living outside
right you live outside and you don't
have any clothes you are completely
submitted to time you are completely
submitted to space you you you are like
a breeze in the wind you know and you
change depending on what goes on you
have no you have nothing stable on which
to stand you know which will fight
against the all the all the things that
are going on you know say okay how about
this if you want to understand how space
fixes time how about this let's say you
let's say you work you know you have an
office and you sit in your office and
amador and you have you know your space
and everything and then you're working
on your computer it's nice nice and
concentrated all right now take your
computer go sit in the children's park
let's say or go go - go - go go outside
go somewhere that you are not in control
of the space and see if you can
concentrate see if you can if you can
resist change you know see if you're not
going to be distracted if you're not
going to be bothered if someone's not
gonna come in and Hey Joe how's it going
blah blah blah blah
you're like no I need just I need to
focus I need to do this but but but no
you're gonna be distracted right and
that's the idea that space fixes time
because if you create the limited space
then you are preventing these all these
distractions all these things outside
from coming and changing the purpose of
what you're doing or the the stability
of your existence right um I hope that
makes sense you know I can only give you
examples if you don't understand it I
think that example is a pretty good one
hopefully it hopefully it'll be enough
all right so norm grenade says in your
videos about time and space you
mentioned that you think we are in a
period of D incarnation I wonder if you
can expand on that idea more as to what
you mean by that and some examples of it
in the world so you know I talked about
this before I think that since the 12th
century we we've had this slowdee
incarnation which is that on the one
hand we have projected spiritual things
that's a very high we have this idea of
God as being separate from manifestation
you know the idea of God of the
clockmaker you know that the deist idea
that God is up there and he made
something made some things and then we
have the idea of below and so that D
Carnation it it happens in all different
spheres and so you can imagine as the
duality of the tree of good and evil
kind of pulling you apart so you you
have in art you have a tendency towards
classicism and so a kind of a kind of
extremely formal system very controlled
everything is very straight everything
is uh is in line and then you have a
tendency towards the baroque towards
romanticism and then everything starts
to get messy everything starts to to get
to be more lyrical and everything you
have that in poetry you have that in
music you know you have a Mozart you
have Beethoven it's like you know and so
you sososo that's you you just see that
in culture and it just keeps just keep
swinging back and forth you know and the
the you know you can use it you can
understand it as Jordan Peterson's idea
that if once God goes away then
swing between nihilism and
totalitarianism you know and that's
maybe the the easiest way to understand
especially if you guys have all
understood Jordan Peterson that is a
form of the Incarnation the the reality
has to be a balance of the two has to be
a balance of of you know of the the
ordering principle and the potential
that's what the human being is that's
what incarnation is that's what you know
the gathering of dust and the spirit
that comes into the body like the
creation of Adam but as we split then
what we have for example like you can
see it if you look at kind of New Age
spirituality you know they have this
idea of spiritual the spiritual world
that is completely separate from the
physical world that is that is uh you
know that that these that these beings
are out there and they're they have
nothing to do with us they're not
they're not the principalities of our
world they're like these beings that
exist in heaven and you know whatever
they interact with each other and you
can encounter them but but the reality
is that those are connected that the
principalities are the they're related
to the way the world is is happening so
there's a there's an essence and a
substance and those two things are
together and that's the ultimate that's
the Incarnation 'el view of the world
and so so you you you get glimpses of
that all the time you know people who
who are like even the new boot even the
new Buddhist you know it's like they
they'll have their they'll have like
their spiritual practices and then
they'll have their very secular mundane
life and there's no connection between
the two it's like one is not informing
the other they somehow can can be a
think that their this this like
enlightened Buddhist person and at the
same time they're leaving their wife and
their you know whatever and so it's it's
like how do you how do those those
things need to be connected together you
can't you can't be an enlightened
spiritual being and then also be this
chaotic passionate thing all right
all right okay so so Normand Wintermute
asks what is your view on Dugan
regarding beards okay he points out that
shade beards originate ultimately from
homosexual prostitutes in Rome who are
the first and at a time the only one to
shave their beard to indicate their
profession and to look more like women
he also brings up here the great law
against beards and other historical
instances like this and he highlights
the ancients of all the importance of
beards I understand so this might be an
exaggeration but given the symbolism of
beards and masculinity I would ask why
did you decide to symbolically castrate
yourself this question is somewhat in
jest of course but I am actually curious
to see he responds god bless all right
so Norman III would say that the idea
that the idea that that that shade
beards in Rome had to do with male
prostitutes that's very odd I've never
heard that I don't know I don't know
what where that comes from I would say
that the there are different reasons or
different reasons that can be attributed
to shaving your beard and therefore the
the beard the shaving of the beard could
have different symbolic aspects in Rome
the idea of shaving your beard and the
idea of having short hair seemed to be
related to to discipline right removing
the excess purity removing the the
messiness of something and so that can
be part of the symbolism of shaving your
beard it has to do with like I said
removing the messiness but it is also it
is also true that being beardless or
shaving your beard can be used as a
feminizing tendency and and we see it
you look just look at advertisements
today you will you will get that you'll
get advertisements that use you know
feminized men and that are beardless and
so I'm not saying that that it cannot
also be part of of having a shaved beard
because in in I can
for example not having a beard is
usually has to do with you being a youth
that has to do with something someone
being young not mature and so the beard
ends up being more like this this kind
of like glory you could say of the
person you know how it's like experience
which grows out and you can see the
fruits of the person as they get older
you know just like in the Bible you know
he talks about how the that the white
hair is a is the glory of the of the
person and so and then it also is
attributed to to androgyny and so the
angels are also beardless because
they're androgynous and also to women
but you can see like for example the the
in the angels are beardless and they're
androgynous but it's not necessarily
seen as feminine it's just androgynous
so I don't know I don't know what to
answer but but for sure I'd never heard
that before
okay so Ian denno asks reading my to his
book I was very intrigued by the
symbolism of the seven-day week with
that similar to mine how do you feel
about the two-day weekend haha best
wishes to you and your family I don't
know where the two-day weekend started I
don't totally understand I mean I'm
happy I have a two-day weekend I don't
necessarily know how it started like
what was what was how it originated um
so I don't quite know how to answer that
you know it's interesting that that it's
the end of the beginning so it's like
you take the end of the beginning days
off it does seem to be a weird idea of
kind of on the one hand celebrating the
Sabbath and then also celebrating Sunday
that seems to be something that's going
on there I'm not sure one thing that has
happened which is strangely enough and I
talked about that with my kids is that
the fact that we have like Saturday and
Sunday off is that everybody thinks that
Monday is the first day and so that has
actually changed this so it's like
Monday is not the first day sunday is
the first day and it's very important to
understand that and you go to church on
Sunday it's the first day and it's the
beginning of the week it's the new
creation it's all that it's very
important to understand that but because
of the two Day weekend
people tend to think that Monday is the
first thing of the week and so the
symbolism is is weird [ __ ] we're
straightly shifting in their in their
in their minds because of that sorry I
can't give you a better answer than that
but it's I don't totally I I haven't
even thought about so maybe I can think
about it at some point I can maybe get a
better answer for you all right so two
more questions left in the official Q&A
and then I will be perusing the chats
and seeing what you guys have come up
with so Dee says I have tried
contemplating random objects natural and
man-made to see what meaning is
inherited them I'm doing this in an
attempt to understand the difference
between a symbol representation created
by the intellect and a real symbol for
example looking at a fence I proceed the
way divided space and then suddenly the
function of boundary is seem to open up
to other objects yes that's that's a
great exercise D are looking at a cup I
get the idea of enclosing space
container I see there is an overlap with
the boundary of the fence yes and then I
allow myself to open up two functions of
drinking my question is if what I
described as a crack approach tell me if
not that is a great approach that is
actually the best approach I think our
Christian symbol is always routed in
phenomenological meaning in all their
layering or are there also layers of
more arbitrary conventional
conventionally created representation
symbols that I just need to learn by
study and memorization I do believe that
the deepest symbols have that reality
that you're talking about and I think
that the way that you're approaching it
is really a great way to approach it to
meditate on the function of something on
the on the phenomenological you know
reason for something and then then see
the analogies with other things around
it that is that's a wonderful way of
doing it now one of the problems is that
this is the problem it is that you do
have some people who are excessive in
the way that they interpret symbolism
and so they look at every single detail
of something and then they try to
attribute meaning to them and so it's
not because it's not because we have
this notion that everything is symbolic
in the sense that everything kind of
comes together that you know what the
symbolism is you know you know just
because just
I believe that in principle does it mean
that you tell me that this means that
doesn't mean that that it's true you
know and so sometimes people can slip
and sometimes also different things can
have actually have different meanings
depending on which angle you're looking
at it from um but I do think that there
definitely are more there are some signs
you could call them in Christianity
which are a little more let's say that
are just kind of pointing to something
that are that are less structural and
and I think that that it that some of
those you're gonna you just have to
learn like I said for example you know
you see you see that that Christ's hand
who'd given Christ does the the blessing
hand people will say you know it
represents his name right it's like I
see XE the yeast was Christo's
you know and you think well that's just
that that's not that's just that that's
just a something that's pointing
something else like a word write a word
the words don't word doesn't necessarily
in its structure have the meaning within
the structure sometimes it actually does
it's once in awhile it can happen but it
doesn't necessarily mean that it does
and so there are some signs like that
which are not as ontological and or more
like words that are pointing to meanings
and so those you just have to like you
said you just have to learn them and you
know it's like for example on the mother
of God in the in the icon of the mother
of God
she has three stars on one on her
forehead and on her shoulders and the
tradition says that this represents her
perpetual virginity that she was a
virgin before during and after birth and
and you would think like I don't I don't
totally see what that has to do the
three stars have to do with virginity or
have to do with perpetual virginity you
know I'm thinking maybe they're not
stars maybe they're flowers like if they
were flowers maybe that would help I'm
not sure and so it's like I just take it
I just accept it and what I'm doing is
I'm also just keeping that in the back
of my mind and sometimes there are some
things like that where I've learned by
heart I just know because it's just
there the culture
and then I just keep it in the back of
my mind and sometimes just it just pops
and all of a sudden I can see the actual
more profound symbolism the more the
more structural symbolism in that image
and sometimes maybe it's not there
because it's it's more like it's more
like a word it's more like a sign that
that points to hope that helps so Ryan
Tinkham asks hey Jonathan sometimes when
I tried to explain st. Maximus and the
Logie to people they think I'm drifting
into pantheism which I don't believe is
correct maybe I'm just not explaining it
clearly does that happen to you
how would how do you respond I think
that the way to understand that the
Logie are not pantheistic is to
understand that they are gathered into
Christ that it's not that they have they
have they have existence in themselves
it's not that they that they are
completely independent but rather all
the Logie are gathered into into let's
say the loge ease of creation are
gathered into the human person right
we're the ones who see meaning in the
world
so those loci are gathered into us and
then ultimately we art human nature has
been taken into God by the Incarnation
and so human nature so then those Logie
are then also let's say brought into God
and are dependent for their being on God
and so it's not it's not like it's not
it's not like God everything is God or
that everything is a God it's it's
rather that God holds all the Logie in
himself and that God holds the world
together and that ultimately the fact
that there are things the fact that
there is unity and anything the fact
that there are qualities is all
something which is held by God and I'll
point to that which holds them together
and so all of creation points towards
man and man points towards God which
means that all of creation points
towards God so it's in that sense that
thing kinda comes together and moves up
towards divinity and so what-what
pantheism tends to do you know the bad
the bad pantheism or whatever is that
they tend to only view these
principalities or these these essences
in the world as having a kind of
independent existence and then they
fight amongst each other and and then
you have to placate them because you
know you need to please them but rather
you know in traditional manner
it's rather than all of this kind of
kind of flows it flows to brings is
brought together and is it is entered
into God all right so I hope that
answers all those questions all right so
let's now go in the chat and see with
all you crazy people are talking about
how do I know which to which super chat
was put out first let's see I think it
goes this way maybe not I don't get so
it starts all right so let's just go
just go through there aren't that many
so I'll just go through them and and I
will see all right okay so free speech
club says it hope as well with the
family keep up the good fight god bless
from Angela Cooper and the FSC yeah
they're the guys who organized the the
event that I did when Peter sat in on in
in Vancouver which was awesome and
hopefully we can do something again one
day
so Michelle Alta says can you explain a
bit more about the issue with verve a
key I understand your point but he
thinks we can just keep going with a new
way of integrating integrating what his
research shows without social cohesion
um I mean yeah I don't I don't like I
said I don't I don't agree with with
John on that on that on that front I do
not believe that I do not believe that
it is enough to have a have individual
practices or to have and I think that
his research shows ultimately that we
narrative and we also and we also need a
narrative which binds us together I
think that his research shows that and
so I I that's why I insist on the
importance of understanding that you are
in a story whether you want it or not
and and until you know until the return
of Christ until the Trent and until
something changes until something new
comes then we are we are bound we are in
the Christian story if you're in the
West if you're Western and if that's the
story you're in and you can either play
a subversive element in that story or
you can play a cohesive element in that
story and those two exist in and maybe
sometimes you need subversive elements
in order to wake up you know the
Christians because they're just kind of
drifting and they don't understand what
they're doing I think that some of the
some of the atheism that has happened in
the West has been a way for for
Christians to wake up and you're seeing
it like all the people that I have been
in contact with some of the people that
have been following my videos and have
gone from atheism into orthodoxy
atheism was a step in actually
discovering a deeper vision of God that
was more related to how reality works
and so sometimes they're subversive
elements are needed questions people
asking questions so but what I'm saying
is that you you can't avoid it
you can't avoid being part of this story
if you are in the in the West I hope
that makes sense all right so the golden
thread says Jonathan why can't pattern
simply be a property of the material
universe and our recognition of them at
an adaptation to that is the logos
necessarily precedent and independent
from the material so the logos is not
totally independent from the material
and that's the thing that st. Maximus
points to is that on the one hand you
can see the meaning of something as
being separate from its you can see so
let's use let's use the word like a
pattern see when you say you say
patterns simply be a property of the
material universe and it's like if the
material universe is that which can be
measured and quantified if that
what it is the pattern and property
cannot be quantified there they're not
their patterns their patterns which then
can be it's like a triangle does not
have quantity it's a pattern
it has quantity once you make a triangle
in the world once you draw a triangle on
a piece of paper then you can measure
the sides but the the pattern of the
triangle is spiritual it doesn't doesn't
have a doesn't have a body but it can
only exist with the body that is there
are note there is no transcendent
triangle how can I say this that the
triangle has to incarnate for it for you
to know what a triangle is and so those
two two things are connected right we
have an incarnation on vision of this
and so say Maximus talks about how he
says you know when you're in a spiritual
contemplation and you see the essences
separate from the material
manifestations then you notice that
they're not contradictory that they're
actually they actually one manifest the
other that they're that they're meant to
be together right Christians say that we
are meant to have bodies we're not we're
not meant to be disembodied there is no
there is no the patterns manifest in the
world I don't that make sense i I'm not
sure it's not making total sense but the
logos has to precede the logos has to
precede in the sense that without the
pattern there is no world there's only
potentiality there's only there's only
scattered disconnected things and so the
logo shines light right the logos is the
light which shines upon that and shows
us the world like the world appears
through logos and so without without
logos what is there you know what is
there I don't know it's just and so and
so so it has to
proceed you know and in some manner it
has to transcend but then it also has to
incarnate it has to end it has to show
us that's what it does it shows us the
world because it patterns it what they
make sense stop to talk about this stuff
you know so hi Jonathan do you think
Dawkins theory of the meme is true or
useful also have you read the
revolutionary phenotype by JFK TV no I
have not read that book by JFK EP um and
do I think that Dawkins theory of the
meme is true or useful I think that it's
I don't know if it's true it's
definitely useful I think it's useful in
the sense that there are some aspects of
it which are useful too he cut because
what he does is he he kind of he's able
to he's at least taking into account
patterns of behavior and patterns of
thought he's at least taking that into
account he's he's take he's actually
seeing that it's something and so it's a
beginning and so I think it's possible
to ride the idea of the meme um you know
and and and I think I saw this one
interview with Joran Petersen which I
thought was really interesting in order
where he uses the meme where he talks
about how even in evolutionary terms
that at some point the meme becomes so
strong that it actually influences
biology so it's not just that this meme
comes out of the of biology but that but
that the meme then transforms the way
that the the evolutionary process
happens and so it's very that's a really
really interesting that's a really
interesting idea for someone who
believes in Logie or believes in
patterns that actually manifest the
world and so it's something stuff to
think about I don't think about that
stuff a lot because I don't feel like I
need it you know you know I like I said
I don't feel like I need it so it so I
don't think about it a lot I if I see
something interesting I'll take it and I
don't probably like I said writing it to
help people understand others
but I don't uh yeah I don't tend to all
right let's go
so one more thing also Derick Bowser
continues he says yeah DP suggests means
developed to serve genes interests the
same way DNA may have originated to
serve RNA which is older uh I guess I
mean I don't know you know ok this is
what I this is what I I like to do in
this case is as I as I always would like
what I would really like to see
evolutionary thinkers do is is explain
the evolution evolutionary theory
through evolution like explain to me why
evolutionary theory appeared using this
idea that memes serve DNA it's like how
did we get there how did we get to
science how does science how does
science serve the genes interest not so
sure not so sure that that that it's
it's easy to get to that so so I think
for me that's that's probably the only
thing that I can say alright so that
last thing by Derek browser he says
lastly says memes are developing
technology to serve their interest but
will eventually the hierarchy will
switch as in the other two cases Thanks
oh that that idea that technology I'm
not sure I understand that that that
comment me because I don't know enough
about evolutionary biology so sorry
alright let's keep going alright let's
see
so Michelle Alta says going back to
rebecky how does the family especially
kids fit into his world view or an
individualistic worldview I don't know I
don't know I don't know how were Vicki I
mean I don't you know I I encountered
reveille key and I watch some of these
videos I haven't watched all of his
series yet I hope to I probably will
watch the whole series um especially
since the flood I have had no time I
know I'm not on YouTube anymore
usually I listen to YouTube videos and
in podcasts while I'm carving but I
haven't been carving because I don't
have a
and so I've been mostly dealing with
with our house and the government and
traveling and all this stuff so I have
not but you know maybe once I I i get
more sense of her Vicki I can I can see
how he sees the family in that in his
vision all right so let's see so Stephen
Anderson says asked will you ever watch
Avatar The Last Airbender anime haha and
the thing with the anime is that it's
like a million episodes that's the
problem is is I really struggle with
those series that are just so many so
many I just don't have time to do that
and so I it's not that I don't want some
of these some of the things some
sometimes people talk about and I
something loop it's really interesting
you know it's like an interesting idea
people told me you should watch full
metal alchemist because it has a lot of
this Christian symbolism in it and stuff
and I'm looking at it I'm like it's like
20 but first series you know all these
episodes oh man whatever I don't have
the time to do it so you know I don't
know I mean maybe I've heard it I've
heard that it has a lot of interesting
stuff in it maybe I should just read
episode descriptions and get a sense of
what's going on so that I don't have to
spend the time watching it like I said
it's like I watch this i watch this this
series this Good Omens series and I kind
of looked at it and I'm like is the
whole seat is the whole story told you
what I think is like six episodes
alright I can I can do that I can do
that no it's like three movies in a few
weeks I can handle that hahaha but like
these series that go on and on man it's
tough all right all right so Derek
Bowser asked one last question he says
would you consider doing an episode on
symbolism in art by famous schizophrenic
artists like Carlos and Ellie Adolph
wolf Lee and Jonathan Bowden I don't
think I've ever heard of those guys
hmm
looking at it now uh I mean I don't know
I would have to love to have to see I
have to see I've never thought about
that you know it is possible sometimes
that mentally ill artists sometimes tap
in to something that is maybe less
protected you know a bit more intuitive
or a bit more direct and so it is true
that I've looked at some like it's the
same which kids art when you look at
children's drawing sometimes and there
are some amazing symbolism in their
drawings because they it's like I think
and I draw you know and they they don't
feel like they need to impress or they
don't feel like they need to they just
kind of it's like this direct intuition
that goes straight on the paper um all
right all right guys I'm looking through
the question through that there's
there's all these comments I mean I
can't read all the calm so what do you
guys think of this I this this whole
life thing you know I I still rise still
I still want to kind of give priority to
the people who are supporting me because
it's like I don't know what to offer
them you know I'm so grateful for people
that people are helping me to do this by
supporting me on patreon so I've been
trying to uh so I want to still want to
give them priority in terms of the
questions but um but I'm thinking you
know I'm I see there's like 150 people
online watching this so I'm thinking
maybe it might be interesting to try
this live Q&A thing once in a while
trying to maybe still give priority to
my my supporters so I don't know what
you guys think about that I then see
John Doe asked a question he says I'm a
proud weeb John can you watch the
berserk the Golden Age arc also what do
you think about Newman's book on
consciousness I don't know what isn't
we've I don't even know what a weeb is
am I too old to know what a weave is a
weave sets with Japanese culture huh
interesting
uh no I I don't know I've never heard of
that like I said I don't I'm not gonna
watch like all these animes there's so
many anime okay I've watched a few
series in my life I think I I don't I
think Mets you're actually once-mighty
my brother he
convinced me to watch Death Note just
because he said like the writing is so
good and so I remember watching that but
I just watched very little
I've watched a little bit of that series
on what's it called
I forget the name of the one that has
like the Giants and like these giant
monsters that are attacking City that is
surrounded by walls I watched a little
bit of that because I was when I saw the
premise I thought oh my goodness this is
an amazing premise with Giants and the
walls just kind of concentric walls of a
city so uh yeah so I don't know what
that is and also what do you think of
Newman's book of consciousness I don't
know I haven't read it I'm not I should
read it
I should definitely read it I'd not I'm
gonna I think I've spoiled this for you
many times I am NOT I am NOT a I'm not a
in Union so you know it's tough because
just I I I mean I'll take whatever I
take from young but I'm just not Union
and so all right so I mean told that
there are more super chats if I scroll
up I need to do this I think to see all
the super chats how do I see on the
super chat I have no idea how this works
I'm told they're more super chats if I
scroll up so as I'm scrolling up I'm not
finding more super chats huh so I
find them maybe what about this maybe I
need to maybe I need to no idea maybe I
need to like follow the super chats as
they're happening maybe in order to get
all of them cuz I don't see any that I
haven't answered yet except for the one
that said except for the one that used
that used that was just talking about I
was just using scatological language so
let's see there's so much other piece
here okay so so Gustavo Luiz asks some
thoughts on Brazilian art I don't know
much about Brazilian heart so I don't
know what that means so okay so the
super chat guys I'm learning this okay
super chats appear on the top and then
they kind of fade out kind of go away so
that mean that I have to click on them
as they're happening is that what he
means and sorry guys if I miss some of
your super chat stuff I don't I'm not
sure how this works so I'm trying to
figure it out one day if I do this again
I'll try to be more attentive to the to
the stupid chat stuff and try but I like
I said I'm not gonna just read all the
super chats like people do so if you're
gonna write a super chat and write
something silly some kind of you know
some kind of something horrible I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna read it but I will
try to answer them next time if I try to
do this I'm gonna think about it and
we'll see we'll see
so Jacob Jacob is warning me that I've
reached a time limit Jacob Jacob knows
that uh yeah that that's what happens
alright okay so I will so next time I
will I if I do this public again I
promise you guys next time I am going to
try to try to keep to keep the super
chats in line so that I don't so I don't
miss it so if you guys are giving me
giving me money I will answer the
question so sorry about that guys if I
miss some all right so we've been going
for about a half an hour and a half
that's usually how long I do the how
long I do the the q and A's and so I
really appreciate this it was actually
kind of fun to see all this
this activity in the in the chat so I
will think about it maybe I'll do that
maybe I will prioritize those that are
supporting you but then do it public so
that so that people can get involved if
they want to all right guys you can
filter it to only see super chance what
I don't see that no I can't sorry guys
if I can filter it to see just a super
chat I don't know where to find that
alright guys sorry sorry if I missed a
super chats the first time I get I
hopefully I am forgiven
hopefully nobody sent like some crazy
amount that I didn't see go bye ha ha ha
that would not be good if I did if you
did send some crazy amount and I did see
go by you can find you can write me send
me an email or you REME send me a direct
message on Facebook or Twitter and I'll
try to try to to answer if I can so guys
thanks for coming it was a lot of fun to
have you guys on board I really did
actually did enjoy doing this live thing
and so maybe uh maybe we will do that
I'll do that again alright guys see you
maybe in a month